hallo herzlich willkommen meine torten
welt heute gibt es bei uns eine
gemüsesuppe ich werde jetzt gleich eine
groko die suppe zu bereiten
und ihr dürft gerne mein zu schauen
dieses rezept soll nur eine anregung
sein ihr könnt natürlich jedes andere
gemüse verwenden die suppe schmeckt auch
ganz gut wenn ihr stadt brokkoli
blumenkohl verwendet oder karotten ihr
könnt ja eigentlich alles nehmen was ihr
gerade habt und aus gemüse schön
mischung und die zutaten für die eine
police suppe zeigen sich jetzt für die
suppe braucht ihr einen pro kollege herz
500 gramm eine zwiebel und eine
knoblauchzehe dann braucht ihr 750
milliliter wasser und ich nehme noch
zwei brühwürfel das sind die von
alnatura die gemüse prüfen
ohne hilfe und geschmacksverstärker und
ihr braucht 200 gramm schlagsahne und
dann entweder crème fraiche schmand oder
eben frischkäse und zuerst das gemüse
vorbereitet den rest könnt ihr zur seite
stellen
der brokkoli der wird jetzt so geputzt
als ich schneid hier
dieses ende ab und teilen dann die
röschen hier ab und es wird dann gleich
gewaschen und das schädlich immer ganz
gern und geht den strom dann auch noch
mit dazu
und hier die harten stellen wenn ich
noch weg das mache ich jetzt einmal kurz
im wasser ab und zeigt euch dann wie es
weiter geht und dann zerteilt ihr hier
noch die röschen schön klein
stell dir kurz zur seite und kümmert
euch so lange um die knoblauchzehe und
die zwiebel
zwiebel fein gewürfelt und wie man das
richtig macht
seht ihr in dem peter video jetzt kommt
ein bisschen öl in euren topf etwa 1 2
esslöffel und dann schwitzt ihr da die
zwiebeln darin an die müssen auch nicht
sehr fein gewürfelt werden die suppe
wird nämlich spieler noch püriert
ein bisschen angedünstet jetzt kommt
auch der foconi mit dazu und den jüngst
etwa fünf minuten netz
er steht damit etwas
da kommt die grüne ffl mit dazu
deckel müsste das jetzt aufkochen lassen
und dann etwa zehn bis zwölf minuten
köcheln lassen
wenn die brokkoli damit weicht sind für
ihr tier ist sie mit einem mixstab
die sahne mit dazu und wenn ihr noch ein
bisschen schärfer dazu volt gebt ihr
etwas cayennepfeffer mit dazu ganz
leicht und da passen jetzt auch ganz gut
kräuter mit dazu wie oregano oder
thymian je nachdem was euch besser
schmeckt das wird dann noch mal
eingeführt
da machen esslöffel schmandt creme
fraiche oder eben frischkäse mit dazu
schon zehn ihren für die ko phase
nämlich einfach weißes brot also so
toastbrot und schneit es sind
gleichmäßige würfel
ihr müsst ihr schon vorher auch nicht
ins rennen
das auf
4 das beträufelt ihren mit etwas
olivenöl oder geschmacksneutrale möhle
und da kommt dann noch ein bisschen salz
mit drauf und das verstehe dann schön
miteinander kommt es da etwa 220 grad so
lange in den ofen ist die kritische
knusprig sind
es dauerte etwa fünf bis zehn minuten
nach dem backen sehen die croutons sieht
so aus köln statt öl auch kräuterbutter
oder knoblauchbutter nehmen und dann
braucht ihr auch gar kein salz mehr dazu
bonn germany
zu jeder station
ihr könnt die super natürlich auch ohne
not aus essen
die crews könnt ihr auch zu anderen
zucken abserviert oder die eignet sich
auch ganz gut als salatbeilage die sind
ziemlich schön knusprig so viel spaß
beim nachmachen und bis zum nächsten mal
aber so
baschari
halloween
es ist ein gruss
drechsel samsung